it's weird that you won't save it you'll
stick to the pay review recommendations
because this is what you said about them
last year and when you're talking about
pay there and you tweeted to say we have
an independent pay review body which the
unions campaign to set up and we will
continue to defer to that process to
ensure decisions balance the needs of
staff and The Wider economy so you'll
defer to the pay of your body when you
like what they say but you reserve the
right to ignore them when you don't I
think when I was on the show previously
you criticized me for adhering to the
full pay review body because there was a
pressure to go further there was
questions in terms of because of the
changing inflation you were saying we
shouldn't just stick to the full pay
View Rd we should actually go further
and indeed the government